y la mayoría más diversa en la historia
tenemos 60 por ciento de mujeres y
personas de color
nuestra diversidad en nuestra fortaleza
en nuestra unidad es nuestro poder este
mes
mientras en eeuu marca el primer siglo
del voto femenino
tenemos a varias mujeres en la cámara de
representante y orgullosamente 90 de
ellas son mujeres las mujeres nunca se
han dado por vencidas estamos en sus
espaldas llevando el trabajo que no
habían terminado
desde cero esto hace cuatro años cuando
el presidente obama y el vicepresidente
joe biden estaban en la casa blanca nos
hicieron sentir orgullosas hicieron
nuestro país maravilloso y este espíritu
está con nosotros ahora no para
llevarnos hacia el oscuridad sino hacia
adelante ese es el propósito de guiar es
de los demócratas luchar por la gente
hemos impulsado proyectos de ley para
subir los salarios y para proteger los
derechos y por ejemplo llevar a la
justicia a la muerte de coldplay de la
equidad de la comunidad lgbt y para
preservar nuestro planeta generaciones
futuras e incluso mucho más todo esto es
posible para eeuu quien está en el
camino
mitch mcconnell y donald fund nuestra
nación enfrenta la peor catástrofe en
nuestra historia
con millones de personas infectadas con
el coronavirus y 170.000 han muerto los
héroes que han estado actuando es
esencial seguir guardando sus vidas y la
vida de nuestra democracia y quien se
está interponiendo mitch mcconnell
en vez de aplastar el virus están
aplastando al obama y los beneficios de
las enfermedades preexistentes he visto
el irrespeto de donald trump hacia las
mujeres en particular que se traduce en
sus políticas y en nuestros derechos y
en nuestra salud no solo en su conducta
pero sabemos lo que no ha hecho lo que
él no sabe que cuando las mujeres tienen
éxito eeuu tiene éxito así que llevamos
el poder de las mujeres para llevarlo a
nuestra vida nacional para que las
mujeres puedan defenderse estén con un
cuidado seguro y fácil para sus niños
con un sueldo equitativo pero quién está
interponiéndose mitch mcconnell y donald
trump
así que quieres nuestra respuesta vamos
a recordarlo en noviembre cuando
elijamos a yo bailé su presidente su
corazón está lleno de amor por eeuu
y por el bien de eeuu joe biden y tiene
la valentía para liberar tiene el amor
para perseverar joe biden es el
presidente que necesitamos ahora que
mira hacia adelante honesto y auténtico
que nunca ha olvidado por quién está
peleando y kamala harris es la
vicepresidenta que necesitamos ahora
comprometida con nuestra constitución
brillante
la persona que ha sido testigo de las
voces de esta nación y que mostrará cómo
se escucharán nuestra misión es luchar
por el futuro y por los ideales de
nuestros fundadores a darle esperanza a
nuestros niños por los sacrificios de
nuestros veteranos
y sus familias vamos a incrementar
nuestra mayoría en la cámara de
representantes y en el senado y vamos a
elegir a kamala harris vicepresidente
joe biden presidente de los eeuu de
américa de dios los bendiga y dios
bendiga a eeuu